la policía de la moral había
desaparecido de las calles de las
grandes ciudades de Irán y especialmente
de Teherán después de que una de sus
patrullas capturó a la joven de 22 años
maxa a mini dos horas después esta misma
joven fue llevada con muerta de celebrar
un hospital muchos iraníes y testigos
aseguran que pudo o fue golpeada en la
furgoneta camino a la comisaría en
Teherán de allí la rabia de la población
contra la actitud de esta policía de la
moral que en el último año se había
hecho incluso más violenta especialmente
desde el mes de julio que el presidente
Ibrahim racimo al mayor Respeto del velo
ese vestir islámico las palabras del
fiscal general tienen muchísimas
interpretaciones muchos lo ven como ese
primer mensaje mandado desde el sistema
de la república islámica para ver cuál
iba a ser la reacción de la población no
solamente de aquellos que están en las
calles protestando sino también ese
sector más radical que es el que ha
apoyado la República islámica durante
estos 43 años y las reacciones son
diferentes hoy la prensa más radical
dice que se llama malinterpretado Las
palabras del fiscal que nadie está
hablando de abolir esta policía de la
moral Pero también la prensa o en las
redes sociales aquellos que están en la
calle dicen que esto es una artimaña de
la república islámica para desviar la
atención y tratar de destruir o por lo
menos silenciar las protestas lo que es
cierto es que el debate sobre No
solamente la existencia de la policía la
moral que posiblemente saldrá de las
calles o por lo menos bajo este nombre
el debate sobre el velo existe en el
país eso está por Constitución este
vestido islámico Pero él mismo fiscal
dijo que se está debatiendo como
interpretar la Constitución y que en
unos 15 días el parlamento debe decir
que va a pasar